all right Jerry
uh where are you from originally where'd
you grow up you know I was born in uh
Little Rock Arkansas
uh raised there
for uh up until about the time I was uh
12 10 11 12 and then uh I was a troubled
kid with my mother so she sent me to
live with my dad in the Upper Peninsula
of Michigan at an Air Force Base uh in
the early 70s I was uh 12 years old give
or take
how would you describe your childhood
um abusive
lost
confused
my uh
my mother
which
which let me say I've come to understand
why
now but uh my mother was very abusive
physical
she punched me she beat me it was a
ritual at our house to uh
you know give me a belt
bend over the chair and grab the legs
those are the words you heard when my
mother was angry
get over that chair and grab those legs
and shoot
you know she tried to whip us on our
asses
sometimes the belt slung across our
backs or down lower on our legs and
those kind of things but uh
you know
I was very angry about that very
repo wanted to get away from it so I ran
away
at a young age but one of the things I
learned I just wanted to say about
mother as uh you know I love her I loved
her
she passed away of course but uh
the thing I ever want to say about my
mother that's the way she was raised so
she didn't know any different
that's how you treat kids this is how
you raise kids and it's my mother uh
you know what was handed to my mother
what was handed to my grandmother was
handed to me I think it's important for
us to all understand that our parents
our grandparents or whoever came from
what they came from yes and you can
blame them but you have to understand
what they came from was 10 times worse I
agree then and you know but as a 12 year
old 15 13 14 15 Euro you didn't I didn't
think that way you know that came about
later on as I got counseling and and
talked with people about why things are
the way they are why are you the way you
are you know I start my mother
I mean I I can remember my mother at you
know maybe I can remember as far back as
five or six years old my mother beating
me
and uh
so uh you know like I said I love her I
cared about her greatly
very sad when she passed
but uh
you know it's what she was taught so
that's what was happening to me and I'm
guessing you didn't treat your kids that
way
you know once I got counseling once we
went through once I went through a lot
of phases of these things unders and you
you gain an understanding of why this
thing why these things happen
uh you uh
start to realize that you know
thank you things are the way they are
and uh
so once I realized once I realized yeah
well this is something that we can stop
right here
and future Generations won't have this
in there
in the in the realm or whatever you want
to call it so uh
once I realized that I think that was
the goal that's that's what you should
all do that was what we wanted to do and
now my I have grandchildren
and you know I have two daughters that
uh with two children and they're not
they're not being beat like I was and so
that in itself was a an accomplishment I
believe that's because your decision to
not do that to not abuse my children yes
I can't I don't see I don't as a parent
I don't see you I don't understand how
anyone could abuse their child could hit
physically uh disrupt my mother hit
abused in that fashion she screamed she
called us bad names
round ass was a common name for me when
I sat on the couch if I leaned over she
called me a round ass you know just
things like that but you know once again
my mother learned
what she learned
it's my resp it was my responsibility to
change
and I think we did
yeah
once uh I ran away from home I ran away
from her several times my dad was in the
military in the Air Force
and uh they were they had a very bitter
divorce
to a point that you know there was never
anything kind said about the other one
in any shape form or fashion
she finally sent me to live with my
father in the uh
Tundra of Michigan in the Upper
Peninsula Michigan hold it there and uh
you know I learned a new thing that uh I
hadn't seen before and then but part of
My AG as a youth
uh the trouble I got into in those days
um you follow me to Michigan
and it wasn't long before I had issues
with my father
at I ran away from home several times
each time I ran away from home I stole a
car or stole a motorcycle
did something like that and then
um
I I got put into a youth home
from that point from the state of
Michigan took me away from my dad
and sent me downstate to Muskegon to uh
a wonderful place that I didn't know at
the time but a place called Harbor House
and uh the people one of the things I
found I just think I discovered about
Michigan was at that time their youth
Force the people that were trying to
help the young Wayward youths really
cared
and tried everything they could to uh
you know to set me straight and set
other straight
I got a job and uh and I [__] it up by
stealing
from the job
and but they you know they were great
people and since they knew that was
going to happen they knew that before I
knew it
because they had already been through it
and uh
you know I
while I was on Pro on uh on a
restriction at the house for the
stealing I still had to work they wanted
me to get to work
and a carnival came to Muskegon
and the guys in the house said hey you
know they're hiring lumpers down there
to set up the carnival and then they'll
be hiring guys to tear it down so I went
down and uh
a guy gave me a that we were a big group
of people you know and the guys each guy
from the rides or from the uh
uh from the carnival barking places you
know the
spinning wheels and things like that
shoot the water guns they were all going
you know I need I need you to come help
me set up my water gun thing I need you
to help me set up my tent and I luckily
got a place with a guy and I set up
helped him set up his three tents and
set up his crazy ball tent uh set up on
the Midway in Muskegon and uh when we've
got it all set up I thought
I was going back to the Harbor House and
going to you know just then wait till
the carnivals over and then come back
and help him tear it down and he had
said he patted me on the back man I had
never had anybody work like you you know
you want to work here for this week
during the during the carnival with me
you can work in the booth you know
collect coins and stuff
he put me in the booth in a booth and I
raised Harbor House said okay yeah you
can do that
and he put me in the booth and uh
it was you know it was a week I'll never
forget
once they did that
um
we tore the thing down and and we came
to a moment when he explained to me you
know I'm going on to another thing and
if you we had the talk I I'm in a youth
home dude I can't work for you you know
full time
and uh can't travel I'm too young to
travel and he just said you know if well
when you get your troubles straightened
up you come find me and I'll put you to
work and I remember going back to the
Harbor House thinking that's what I'm
going to do
uh figure that out somewhere some way
um
I hung around for a few days for a week
10 days at the Harbor House and all I
could think about was that job
and finally I packed my bags packed a
bag and I jumped and I jumped out the
window and jumped out the back off the
back fire escape and I went to the next
town that that Carnival had gone to in
another part of Michigan
and showed up the next morning and uh
you know he was very nervous he knew my
situation he knew I had run away he said
I'll put you to work but I'm not going
you know if someone comes for you you
know I'm not going to stand for you
so we ended up working that you know
working that event and then working
another one the police did come looking
for me but in 1970
one or two whenever this was you know
there weren't the technology that we
have today so they didn't even have a
photograph of me so they didn't know who
they were looking for just some runaway
kid from a Harbor House
and uh
you know they didn't they didn't find me
so
I fell off the truck
in Tennessee
and uh got injured and that was another
thing I
at 14 15 years old the carnival allowed
me to drive their semi truck
I just said I could do it and I got in
it a little small it was a small semi
flatbed
and uh and I drove it from town to town
and it gave me a uh you know some it put
me gave me the experience
to go you know where I'm where I've
ended up
started my experience to end up where
I've ended up
and uh but I did fall off the ride I got
injured I was in Louisiana and I called
my dad who was worried who at that time
up until that time I had not even
thought
my parents about my parents they didn't
know where I was at they didn't know
what I was doing they didn't know if I
was alive or dead
I couldn't imagine that I could not
imagine that feeling today about any of
my joke
and so uh
when I called my dad he was quite angry
and
he uh
immediately sent the police he didn't
you know I'd call him because he was in
the military and I thought and there was
a military base there in Alexander
Louisiana and I thought somehow I can
get to that base and the medical people
will treat me you know because I'm an
Air Force because I'm the son of an Air
Force guy
and instead my dad sent the police over
and they you know they captured me or
arrested me and and actually you know
they were wonderful people they were
nice guys they weren't mean to me in any
fashion they matter of fact they were
kind of amazed at the 13 14 15 year old
kid had done what I had done you know
and then Michigan sent someone down to
pick me up
went back to Michigan went back to
Harbor House Harbor House said you can't
stay here anymore
[Music]
um
I had a friend who had been in trouble
the idea basically came about because a
friend had been in trouble
and he joined the Marine Corps
and when he came home from boot camp and
his dress blues because he had done so
well in boot camp he got he he won he
got the dress blues he didn't win him he
earned them
and uh when he had left to go to the
Marine Corps he had long hair and his
hippie looking bomb looking guy and he
came back in the Marine Corps uniform
standing straight at tall and now it's
not that's me man I want to be that
because everyone was gathering around
this young man you know telling him
dude you are you know six months before
he was facing prison now he was this
glorious Marine and I thought this is me
this is what I want to do and uh
so then I ended up in the Marine Corps
and uh
you know that was a wonderful learning
time that helped straighten some of my
issues out with youth youthful troubles
but not all of them and when I got out
of the Marine Corps
and went home I immediately started
hanging with a lot of the folks that I
shouldn't have been hanging with and I
caught a robbery charge and a burglary
charge
and ended up going to prison
and uh
you know I I think I probably thought my
whole life would be that way
for a while but then I
you know I don't know what happened to
me I I just was so upset with the
situation with setting with being in an
Arkansas prison on an Arkansas Prison
Farm the prisons are in Arkansas are are
farms so they give you hoes and they
chase you up and down the crop the
fields on Horseback with shotguns the
guards have you know yelling at you to
cut the weeds
and because they don't use chemicals
they got convicts to cut the weeds down
and uh you know I just didn't
I'm so tired of being locked up by that
time by the time I got out of prison
I had spent seven years of my life
behind bars in one way or another youth
homes
you know juvenile Halls
prison jails and uh I'm sick of it
it's just [__] sick of it
and I kind of
vowed to myself you know what I had to
do what someone told me was you know you
got to make a promise to yourself that
you got to keep not what uh
you know not
you can't make a promise to somebody
else and keep it you have to make a
promise to yourself
and somehow or another I did and I got
out
and changed my direction
changed my ideas
on how to be you know what to do
serve my time did my parole
accomplish that the parole man allowed
me to play music because I had been that
was another thing throughout my life was
I played some music
and uh
you know life went on from there I've
kind of grew out of that
and eventually you got into
driving a tour bus eventually I became a
uh Rock And Roll tour bus driver the I
started out as uh
you know I had a
because people in Michigan and and in my
past had been taking chances on me and
encouraging me to do the right thing but
once I got out of prison I had a job I
was playing in a band in a bar band
three nights a week and I was going to a
music store
and getting things on credit from a
gentleman from the guy that owned the
store
Wonderful Life Mentor Mike Pinner
and uh
one day he came to me and said you know
you owe me lots of money and I just
bought a rock and roll stage a stage
that performers perform on and I need
some Roadies to help me set it up and
tear it down
so we went and worked for all week you
know for over a week for the big
Festival it happened and went off and
when I got back you know Mike had Mike
shoved a thousand dollars in my hand in
cash and then I had to pay him a few
bucks that I owed him of course and you
know he said we're going to do this
again
and he patted me on the back and told me
you know what a great job I had done and
that wasn't too much I hadn't gotten too
much of that in my life
and uh
you know we did that for a while I
worked on that staging for a while and
then a company said they needed a truck
driver to haul rock and roll gear
I worked that angle for a while and then
I actually stepped you know eventually I
worked my way into driving buses I drove
entertainment trucks and trailers
pulling shows but then I also in between
started hauling uh Freight and produce
eventually purchased my own truck so I
could keep the payments up the shows
would were sporadic
and the tours were sporadic so in
between I would haul
stuff from Arkansas to California pick
up produce and take it back to the
Midwest uh saying it run the South Texas
routes with Pro of hauling produce
because I own my own truck in the those
days you could haul exempt Freight which
was something that wasn't regulated
so I hustled exempt freight loads and
from California to New York
and then in the meantime I went and uh
you know I worked the shows
um
eventually I I got rid of that truck and
uh got into a bus and
it's been a good it's been a steady
career so tell me about that how did it
how did that all get going and what
bands would you drive for well you know
I've driven for uh more than 100
different acts over the years uh from
you know Aerosmith Dave Matthews Band
The
some memorable stuff like R Kelly
Millie Vanilli Van Halen was a awesome
tour Bruce Hornsby The Grateful Dead I
drove them
Pearl Jam Eddie Murphy tour kiss Keith
Keith Urban
Courtney Love just just a lot of them
more dozens many some I don't even
remember
um
I was sitting in uh
I was in Biloxi Mississippi with a show
and uh I was working on my truck I was
polishing it cleaning it because I
really like the you know my gear to
shine
and when a guy who owned buses came by
and was like you know God damn man if I
can get a driver to take care of my bus
the way you do this truck you know he's
giving me his card and selling me to
call him and Mario was his name and I
was like you know dude I would never
drive a bus [__] you and uh
but then I ran into a few months later I
ran into a pay making a payment issue
with on my truck and then the next Once
I once you fall a little bit
you're going to fall more so the payment
got uh you know more behind and more
behind to a point that and right at that
period I I saw him again
and he gave me his card again said
basically the same thing you know I want
you to drive buses for me
I went home I got rid of the truck
and I gave him a call I found his card
and
and you know called him hey man you
serious about putting me to work you
know hell yeah let's go let's go and
then day or two later I was on a plane
flying to his shop in Pensacola and
where I got into a bus
I went out and picked up a an old
country band my first uh first band I
hauled in a bus was a country man called
Atlanta
which were their management were
following the theme of Alabama and so
all their artwork all their things kind
of it said Atlanta but you could see
Alabama all over it but they were a good
band and uh and they're I'd pick them up
in Atlanta I took them to they were on
their last leg
and uh I took them to Ohio
where they did a show in in a mall
celebration of the birthday of the mall
in Lima Ohio Mid-America Mall in Lima
Ohio
and I could remember the first day we
drove up
they all like me they all patted me on
the back you know great job driving you
know all this kind of stuff it's you
have to you have to realize it's
it's not easy to get into a vehicle with
someone you don't know and then on top
of it live your life it's your house
sleep while this guy's rolling you down
so they all patted me on the back in
reference to that and uh
I picked them up at the hotel we left
the hotel to go to the gig and and these
guys
they could sing man they could sing like
you wouldn't believe
and uh
I can I remember driving the bus over to
the the mall and these guys were singing
barbershop quartet stuff warming up
because they knew as soon as we got them
all they were going to walk on stage so
they were warming up and they were
singing you know like Sweet Adeline and
five six seven guys harmonizing that you
know it just wow it was amazing and uh
but that's that was the first band I
hauled and then they went to uh they
eventually felt broke apart there was
one of their last few shows and then
from there I went on and and just as an
entertainment bus driver
unless you're fully employed by someone
which is very rare
only a couple in those days had their
own bus someone like Loretta Lynn uh
Conway Twitty those were the country
acts rock and roll acts never owned
their equipment they rent it
you're a big star today with a hit song
and tomorrow you're nobody and you still
got a bus payment so we rent the buses
what kind of things do you see driving a
rock band around the country
you know in the in the 80s I saw lots
and lots of drug use lots of alcohol use
lots of naked women
um
depending on the band you get with if
you get a Young Band that's on its way
up then you're playing small bars so
you're going to places like the worst
part of town and with these uh with a
lot of the Bands where the where the
rough bars are where the good bars are
and you're staying in cheap hotels so
you're in a lot of areas where uh it's
not necessarily the best place to be
drug use prostitutes those kind of
things you see all those kind of things
in the day as you move up the ladder and
you start getting on bigger and bigger
tours the the money causes things to
change of course and
um you'd maybe you stay in a in a Hilton
and I uh you know upper class holiday in
those can you get in better hotels the
better band you get the better hotels
you're going to get out of the deal
lots of strange human behavior when
people are in the Limelight of the show
when they're at the moment at that
moment that their Eros are busting out
and you could you could just about do
anything to people I mean they're just
in awe they're stare at their Joy on
their face you know their action of
their bodies
there's no place like being at a live
music event and and feeling it and you
know everyone has their heroes in the
world and to see one of your favorite
musicians uh
it's always a happy time and that's I
think that's one you know that's what
draws me to this business it's always
happy out front I mean you know
backstage we're working our asses off
but uh out front it's just this
atmosphere of
there's nothing else in the world that
matters but the music and and this
moment and that's uh that's a good
feeling there's hardly ever any violence
or critical bad things going on you know
because of drug use
continued or is it tapered off in recent
years you know in the 70s and the 80s uh
it was all about sex drugs and rock and
roll but now it's about business
business
and uh eventually the the drugs are
still there
but they're not the primary reason we're
out there anymore which seemed to be the
reason we were out in the 80s
uh you know the drugs there's uh you
know of course as a driver you can't do
drugs uh and the musicians the Roadies
it's just not like it was back in those
days it's more business these days and
if you uh you can't do your business
drunk and high uh forever
and eventually you know it catches you
and someone notices and
they get somebody else that can handle
their [__] better than you have you
stayed away from drugs pretty much I
mean I had my uh rent I went through I
put needles in my arms back in the day
uh you know I took all kinds of pills
and tried this acid uh in the 70s in the
in the into the early 80s
um
honestly my second wife when I met my
second wife
my life changed
kind of give up there was more to life
than doing drugs
getting [__] up every day you know
it was you know especially once we had
children
there's
that's high in itself that's that's just
the high in itself having children uh
and so there was no uh you know my life
changed so I pretty much that changed
the business change it all changed at
the right time for me
for me to take the next steps and to
continue uh in a career uh that's taking
me to the you know to the top of the
ladder so to speak
I bet you got some interesting stories
of your I have seen you know
there were guys I mean
in the 80s it's sex drugs and Market
there were girls in the back of the bus
that uh you know honk guys Bobo's you
know there were guys standing in line in
the hallway of the bus to get their Bobo
honked you know uh
those kind of things the enormous amount
I'm
I had a band uh
you know very popular band I'm not going
to say their name uh you know their
biggest thing was they played they
played poker with cocaine on the table
in the bus as I drove him down the road
and uh you know I'd hear them back there
talking and yelling at each other they'd
take their laminates and push push in
some cocaine you know for the BET and uh
and uh you know and there every time
there was a bet made there was an
argument because that ain't enough you
know I put in more than that last time
and so uh you know that in itself it
seemed as if people in the 80s in the
rock and roll time
did this sort of thing for uh it's like
I got a license to do drugs you can't
stop me you know and that was pretty
much the thing they were they were
everywhere drugs that pick you up though
mostly you know barbiturates didn't work
you know too much
uh there weren't too many the English
bands seemed to have more issues with
Heroin than the American bands uh you
know Depeche Mode was a wonderful band
that I got to drive that I got they came
to America
and we we started in the Warner Theater
up in Washington DC at the beginning of
the tour and they became so popular
instantly they grew so fast at the end
of that year we did a show in Pasadena
rosebowl to 100 000 people so uh I mean
they just exploded
um
you were I mean I say that because that
made me think of uh the English bands
I've you know I've driven quite a few
English uh entertainers
European entertainers I'll just say that
not necessarily English but European
but um you know drugs were seem to have
you have a license if you're in the
entertainment business used to be a and
I it looks that way even in the in other
forms of entertainment
yeah drugs are yeah drugs are prevalent
and uh people think they have a license
to do them you know to me the story gets
sad though it gets old it became it
became a story of uh I want to be famous
I can't handle the fame now I'm a Dr you
know I have to do drugs and now you know
now I've got problems it's got it's got
to be difficult for these
musicians who go from being just
struggling musicians to being
Gods Almost sure and you have to
understand the record companies used to
push that sort of thing no but I mean
let's get those guys in this room and
force them to make a song and if they
say well we're tired we can't we'll give
them drugs you know we'll do this for
them we'll do that for them we'll make
sure that they get that song out no but
for an individual to go from being a
regular Joe to being somebody that
everyone is worshiping yes is hard for
that person it's hard for that person to
deal with some days I think I think it
is harder for some than there's others
yes and self-destruction kind of yes
comes right I have seen plenty
make the trip without all the hassle
I have because of my you know because
I've done it long enough now I've seen
I've seen many make the trip with it
with the hassle and I've seen quite a
few now that can do it without all that
you know it seemed like a cop-out to me
back now that you look back it looked
like a cop out now but that was what was
selling sex drugs and rock and roll the
way women were
practically you know paraded is almost
shameful these days to look back
you know I mean if you go to a big rock
show concert and the girls are on guys
shoulders taking their shirts off you
know I mean I laughed we a joke nowadays
is like if a girl did that you'd be like
a girl from those days went to now to
see everybody hey put that back on yeah
hey cover yourself up there but uh
no they uh
so I don't know that's
drugs are part of the business uh myself
I'm with children now with
you know it had to change
it had to change
and you're still driving today I am
still driving today
and uh hoping uh you know it has become
a career a full-fledged career
and a lot of people know me I can get
work if I just raise my hand you get a
nice resume I do have a nice resume I've
seen a lot of entertainers and lots of
shows a lot seen it done a scene
entertainment done many different ways
who's who is one of the most impressive
people you've seen you're driven
you know I'm really honored to work with
the Dave Matthews man they're incredible
musicians
uh
some of the
you know some of the
Jazz musicians take music to Heart uh
just uh man you you catch me with these
questions
I could tell you just like that if you
didn't ask me I hear that you were the
driver on that uh notorious uh the bus
in Chicago that dumped its uh human
waste you know there was an incident of
that happening and I was in Chicago when
that happened but it was not me I had
nothing to do with it at all nothing uh
I was accused of it actually it was your
bus right because I'm driving a bus yeah
and I was accused of it and I just say
that I didn't do that the person who did
it kind of got he got in trouble the
person that did it eventually got found
out got caught got brought before the
court and uh was sentenced to some
punishment but you you your bus ended up
dumping its human waste over the river
on top of a river a boat that was going
through the incident occurred where I
tour bus uh was uh on his way to the
venue on his way to pick up someone and
uh
he as he crossed a graded Bridge he
flipped a switch that allowed his dump
to dump and unbeknowing to him he didn't
look I mean he shouldn't have done it
anyway
there was a architectural Tour Chicago
architectural tour going down the river
I guess it's the Chicago River and uh it
happened to dump on the folks at that
time and so uh you know it was a nasty
mess I couldn't imagine being the victim
I couldn't imagine that
um
so this driver didn't use his head he
caused a lot of
a lot of problems a lot of problems and
you know it's a matter of stopping out
of at a regular place and hooking your
hose up and flipping that switch on your
dash to letting it go and letting it go
in the proper place and he didn't do
that so uh but I had nothing to do with
it even though a lot of folks pointed
their fingers at me
so even even huge bands are still
traveling around the country via bus
right you know it's the cheapest way to
to travel if you have a group of people
uh you can't fly them you can't transfer
them from the hotel from the airports to
the hotels to the gigs and back uh Hotel
them and everything else you can sleep
12 people in a tour bus and uh they can
do their show and get in their home and
go to the next show the next day and get
out and do their jobs and there's not uh
you know it doesn't uh
it it it's expensive it's still
expensive but it's nothing like what it
would be having to fly in the logistics
that you have to come up with in order
to move uh On Any Given tour you're
looking at 50 to 100 people Roadies and
band members and management and
everything else so uh the the world of a
traveling musician yes just must
it's just got to be an interesting
you know if you can adapt to it if you
can adapt to the traveling I honestly
feel the part of the travel has helped
me to stay young you know it opens your
mind to travel opens your mind
you know you'd never seen uh I would
have never seen downtown Los Angeles or
you know or Manhattan for that matter
I've been on I've been to every state in
America and all the providences Canada
I've traveled on every if you open a
Rand McNally map every blue Road I've
traveled on and I've traveled on over
half of the red roads so I've seen parts
of America that are unbelievable
and when I show up when I'm driving a
tour bus if I stop somewhere people are
it's an instant conversation starter
they're oohing it on over what you have
and then you can get the information you
need you know hey what's going on here
what's this place all about do you think
what got these musicians into this
career and to pursue it so
um relentlessly just to become
successful what have you learned about
that character that personality type
because sometimes they're doing it for
reasons that are
other than what it appears
yeah you know I would think that there's
a lot of musicians entertainers I want
to say Entertainer not musician that's a
different thing there's a lot of
entertainers out there who have this
look at me
I'm famous or want to be famous look at
me and then there are
Entertainer there are musicians and
entertainers who actually are
who they're supposed to be
and I believe that firmly I mean there
are people that just dance around and
shake their asses and follow the
mainstream thing to the next thing and
then there are real musicians who really
can break your heart make your heart or
bring joy to your heart and your mind
through their
through them through their their own
well-being and there are people I have
met that I believe that this was there's
no way else you could have been anything
else this is you right here
to entertain the masses does it does it
make the
the tour easier when you're working with
when you're driving somebody who you you
believe in or you enjoy their their
music or their personality you know I
think uh that's an interesting question
maybe yes and no uh it's work you know
it's work it's a Daily Grind you get up
every day at eight o'clock or you know
and you go to work at eight and you work
eight to five it's that grind it's the
same grind in the in the entertainment
business you're not working eight to
five you're working a different shift
but uh it's hard work
and it's hard work to be
to be on the stage it's hard work what
goes on behind the stage and it's hard
work to get from stage to stage
so I lost myself on your question but uh
what was so the the groupies you see a
lot of groupies right not So Much
Anymore we see lots of fan you know
I think the groupie thing has changed of
course depending on what your groupie
idea of a groupie is there used to be
you know all kinds of groupies hanging
up at at hotels at shows you know
following you down the road offering The
Honky Bobo and whatever you know they
just want to be feel part of that and uh
then there are people who just are there
for the music you know for the show uh
for the feeling of it I guess
uh
see a lot I've seen a lot of bad act I
was on a tour in St Louis on uh when
Bobby Brown a new addition Bobby Brown
was with new addition we were in St
Louis and uh you know I guess they had a
Strife with somebody there in St Louis
and guys came by and shot up the bus
with with shotguns and bullet you know
guns shot up bullet holes in the side of
the bus
uh you know I've seen things like that
happen
uh I was on Smashing Pumpkins tour some
years ago and uh the keyboard player
overdosed on heroin so I've seen Lots
I've seen things like that
so it's just a white you know it's a
I've seen uh I've been to venues where
guns were in you know guns were drawn
and people were scared just shitless
bomb threats uh
there's all there seems to be an always
a collection of people around for sure
be they fans be them groupies be them
whatever there's always someone
following do you ever you ever regret
choosing this
line of work
I do not now that I've done it maybe
maybe I had a time or two where I did I
know I did want to stay home with my
family more
but everything it kept drawing me back
to something kept drawing me back to
this this business that it's what's made
me me
uh
what else could I be a drug salesman
there
I mean I don't know what else I could
have done
Jerry what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
oh wow
how to love
how to love I didn't have that when I
was young girl I didn't feel it when I
was younger I know you know Alex is back
at the beginning I know my mother loved
us
my brothers and sisters
uh
but through the years
I've learned a lot I've learned what
love is what's most important with it
and the value of it that's probably the
best the lesson I've learned it's a
great lesson
all right Jerry Fitzpatrick thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
friend wish you lots of luck thank you
thank you
okay